[Music]
well teachers in san diego california
set to offer
in-person learning to migrants starting
today
at that city's convention center while
more than a hundred thousand kids in the
city have not seen the inside of
classroom in san diego in more than a
year
meanwhile hhs officials tell fox news
of the more than 700 migrant girls
transferred to the convention center at
least 82
are covered positive here with reaction
we've got san diego parents
edward ewing and gina smith and their
congressman daryl isaac good morning to
all of you
good morning good morning good morning
how are you steve i'm doing okay edward
uh what do you make of the fact that uh
your
child sky is not in school
not receiving in-person learning and yet
the migrants down
at the convention center are going to
wind up with in-person
volunteer teachers from your school
district as early as today
well it just shows you how out of touch
our school district is
with the needs of the parents and the
desires of the teachers as you can see
local teachers are more than happy to
teach in person and they're being held
up by the district
and by the union which has strong-armed
us the entire time
and has has been indifferent and and
even contemptuous of the parents
and the damage that's been done to our
children sure and gina your
eight-year-old son
bowen uh is at home learning
not in a classroom learning
unlike the migrant children who get
in-person teaching
you you don't like that standard do you
you think it's
hypocritical well you know first i just
want to acknowledge
these teachers who are willing to meet
with these
um migrant children i applaud their
efforts
and their willingness and i've heard
from several teachers throughout the
pandemic who want to get back to the
classroom
so these teachers as far as i'm
concerned they're heroes who are willing
to step up and it's unfortunate that our
teachers
have not had the same opportunity and
really our focus should be
as mentioned to ensure that all children
throughout san diego unified school
district received the same sense of
urgency to return to in-person
instruction
and this demonstrates that it is safe to
return to in-person learning
today right so gina do you blame your
school union your teacher's union for
not uh saying okay it's safe let's go
we've known that for months yes we've
known it for months and i
absolutely hold our district leadership
accountable
and for not stepping up and having that
same sense of urgency
for getting our kids into the classroom
we still have a very
weak hybrid program in place and we
still don't have a clear plan as to how
the district is going to address
learning loss for our students who have
been home for almost 13 months
congressman you don't like the situation
one bit
no not one bit the hypocrisy of
the suburbs having school as as early as
last october some of them reopened
they've done it safely
and then to be willing to send teachers
down to
a known coveted positive area while at
the same time
pretending that they can't come safely
back unless they get
bonuses and additional money uh and even
then they still want to come back on a
hybrid basis
teachers are the heroes teachers unions
are clearly the villains in san diego
and la unified
and it's it's one of the failures of
leadership here in in california
i know a lot of people are concerned
about many aspects of the border
i think for all of us on this
communication
we're not we're not against treating
these people humanely once they're here
certainly i think there's a lot of
question about whether
joe biden is doing a disservice to have
hundreds of thousands of people flooding
the border
who need this kind of care that right
quite frankly we're not able
currently to give to all our citizens
and gina
um edward
sorry got that backwards edward gina
blames the school leadership
you blame the the teachers unions
well it's a coalition of both i mean the
the
uh right now the cdc says three feet is
safe
for the students for our children
in school the union has demanded five
feet now you do the math
that's 40 fewer students in the
classroom
this is an arbitrary number why did they
choose this
it seems like that they're you know
indifferent to the suffering that's been
inflicted upon our children
and our district is not standing up to
the union instead it's cow towing to
them
and as you've seen in san francisco and
chicago they tried to take on the school
districts to force them to follow the
science and open it
gina you're ready gina you're ready to
see
one of the important that one of the
important things to understand in
california is our governor has statewide
edicts one after another
closing restaurants closing places of
business
demanding that we all wear masks but
then when it comes to
saying from a public education
standpoint here is a unified standard so
you all go back to work based on it
then he says well it's hands off it's
going to be every single school and
school district and charter school for
itself
it makes absolutely no sense if you can
say that there's a science
and you're following it on a statewide
basis then quite frankly
the governor uh and and other leaders
who have
locked down the state need to be willing
to
step up and unlock uniformly and they're
not doing it
all right uh congressman thank you very
much and uh we should point out
that the school district says our
teachers are volunteering
gina real quick uh if you could you
would send your child
for in-person learning tomorrow right i
would i would send him to school today
okay even better because it is uh
3 40 in the morning and god bless y'all
for getting up so early
edward and gina and congressman thank
you very much